[Music]
disney pixar's light year goes to
infinity and beyond with a tiny whiny
plot full of twists and turns wondering
how it all connects to toy story dying
to discuss that major plot hole keep
watching for the ending of light year
explained warning major spoilers
straight ahead
every hero has a villain and in the case
of buzz lightyear that villain has
always been zerg the bull horned purple
clad conqueror with the tri-barreled
plasma blaster lightyear brings a big
twist to the bad guy in the film's third
act by revealing that this instance of
zerg is actually buzz himself
specifically he's an old version of buzz
from a split timeline who journeyed far
into the future and then back again
using advanced technology old buzz's
plan is simple he wants to use the
crystallic fusion drive to go back in
time before the star command ship ever
even crashed thereby erasing what he
sees as his greatest failure as it's
explained in the film the first time
buzz successfully achieved hyper speed
he returned home expecting a hero's
welcome instead he was brought up on
charges for going against star command
orders in a daring escape he flies over
a hundred years further into the future
and discovers a ship that holds the zerg
armor and robots using the advancements
available in that far-flung future he's
able to travel back in time but only as
far as his original hyper-speed voyage
that leap back in time creates a paradox
of two buzzes and gives the younger
space ranger a shot at redemption
obviously zerg being buzz is a bit of a
retcon in the buzz lightyear of star
command cartoon the villain was simply
an evil emperor however the twist brings
an interesting new layer to the story
turning buzz's obsession with success
into a dark alternate plotline as it
turns out buzz lightyear's greatest
enemy is actually his own worst self
one of the biggest themes in lightyear
is obsession it's explored early on in
the montage of buzz's mini hyper speed
test runs in each attempt he moves four
years into the future returning home
each time to a colony that has advanced
and changed in many ways sensors
indicate you've missed four birthdays
it's one of the film's most powerful
moments because it shows just how far
buzz is willing to go to achieve what he
views as success and redemption he has
friends on the planet at least one
anyway but that's not enough to make him
want to stay he values his legacy and
his reputation more than he values his
own happiness
and he willingly blows through almost a
century of time while hardly aging at
all the revelation of zurg's true
identity puts buzz's obsessive nature
into stark perspective the younger
character sees his older self in all of
his sadness and regret a man who was so
fixated on making his life perfect that
he forgot to actually live it the lesson
that younger buzz ultimately takes away
is that obsession always leads down a
dark path he realizes that it's better
to live in the world you've got than to
spend every waking hour thinking about
what you could have done differently
after all despite all your effort and
futuristic technology you can't really
change the past
for a hot second it looks like buzz
might take zerg up on his offer to help
him undo their previous timeline it's
the thing that buzz has been trying to
do for so long fix his mistake restore
his reputation and set things right as
he understands them but then he realizes
the magnitude of that decision he
realizes that his best friend would have
never had the life she ended up living a
life filled with laughter and love her
children and grandchildren would never
be born and countless others would
befall a similar fate for all of buzz's
desire to see his mistake mended he
realizes that the stakes of turning back
the clock are too great zerg doesn't
like that kind of thinking though and
they too engage in an extended battle
that ultimately ends in the villain's
defeat the implicit message here is a
pretty heavy one but also a simple one
you can't ever undo your failures and
that's just part of life with enough
time mistakes just become part of
history they become a part of your
legacy which isn't necessarily good or
bad would buzz and alicia have lived
happier lives if they'd never crashed on
the planet in the first place it's
impossible to know we all only get one
life the movie seems to say and it's
better to enjoy it heirs and all than to
lament some other life that might have
been
when buzz jumps forward in time and
discovers the presence of zerg's robots
he teams up with the only folks he can
find to fight back his best friend
alicia's granddaughter izzy a nervous
man named mo and an elderly ex-convict
named darby together with the assistance
of buzz's robot companion socks the team
attempts to take zerk down but they hit
a number of pitfalls along the way many
of the problems that the team ends up
facing are products of their own
mistakes
a recurring theme in the movie mo's
nervousness leads him to make some
errors darby is a little too gung-ho and
izzy's excitability causes her to mess
things up a couple of times and yet in
true pixar fashion those apparent faults
end up being turned into assets by the
end of the movie whether it's mo's love
of the surrender switch on his space
ranger suit or darby's ability to make
anything explode the qualities that make
each character eccentric and odd are
also the ones that help them get the job
done it's not exactly a new idea for a
children's movie to espouse not even
within the pixar pantheon but it still
works quite well in light year buzz's
hyper fixation on a single idea of the
right way to do things is broken by the
oddities of those around him as it turns
out diversity of perspective and
experience ends up being a positive
attribute for the team who would have
thought your mock
yeah but in a supportive way
after successfully stopping zurg's evil
plan and destroying his ship buzz and
company return to the colony where
they're welcomed as heroes buzz explains
that he feels okay about never managing
to get the star command ship back into
space because he realizes that they've
all made a home together on this strange
alien world the perseverance and
determination of the other human
inhabitants seems to inspire him and he
takes solace particularly in the company
of his new friends up until this point
buzz never seems content to sit down and
actually live his life that may be in
part because of his natural personality
one that doesn't lend itself easily to
building relationships but it's also
implied to be connected to his sense of
self-worth in the middle of the movie
buzz shares how he was a major screw-up
at space ranger boot camp and that he
planned to quit after the first week he
was eventually convinced to stay by
commander hawthorne but it's clear that
he still carries that sense of
inferiority with him maybe buzz never
thought he was worthy of a normal and
happy life maybe he always believed that
he had to accomplish great things in
order to accept joy for himself
fortunately his interactions with izzy
darby and mo seem to break him out of
that harmful stupor he recognizes that
all people are deserving of love
happiness and second chances which
allows him to finally accept that he
does have a home
light year is a solid movie but it isn't
without its faults and there's an
especially big one at the end of the
movie in the form of a gaping plot hole
that's a lot of space
all of the action of the third act and
much of the movie prior to that point as
well revolves around the crystallic
fusion drive that buzz creates with
sox's formula he's shown synthesizing
the crystal at one point in the film and
he carries the same one through
everything else zurg tries to use it to
go back in time but buzz manages to
swipe it back
unfortunately the macguffin shatters
during buzz's atmospheric reentry
leaving all the humans still stranded on
the planet
buzz says it's okay that he couldn't
complete his mission but here's the
thing he could sox still has the formula
that resulted in the perfect fusion
crystal and there are surely still
enough resources on the planet to
synthesize a duplicate at least there
are no claims to the contrary that means
that star command could theoretically
leave the planet if they just made
another crystal but nobody even
entertains that idea maybe there's some
other obstacle standing in their way or
some other reason why the crystal can't
be recreated but it's never properly
explained in the film this is a bit of a
perplexing plot hole but fortunately
it's not enough to ruin the movie or its
overall message
though he doesn't get the rest of the
humans back into space buzz does head up
a major new initiative for star command
at the end of light year due to his
heroics he's commissioned by commander
burnside to head up the new universe
protection unit a resurgence of the
space ranger program meant to expand the
influence and safety of the galactic
alliance's burgeoning colony buzz is
given the chance to pick his personal
squad from the best of the best but he
instead declares that he already has his
crew
decked out in a new generation of space
ranger suits buzz mo darby and izzy set
out on their next mission they may still
be a little ragtag but they're battle
tested and stronger than ever in the
first toy story buzz says that he's
stationed in the gamma quadrant of
sector four that's exactly where he's
headed at the end of light year
finally
the ending scene of them blasting off
into space together could be the setup
for a sequel or even a series on disney
plus given what happens in the film's
post-credit scenes those possibilities
seem even more likely
the first post-credits scene comes after
the initial round of credits and shows
commander burnside sitting in his office
through the window you can see a giant
big fly fly up to the colony's perimeter
and promptly get zapped by the laser
shield burnside chuckles and mudders
laser shield to himself clearly proud of
his favorite creation the second scene
takes place after another round of
credits and shows zerg's robotic exo
suit floating in space
the screen zooms in on the evil
emperor's face and shows his eyes flash
back to life then it quickly cuts to
black
clearly this is a potential setup for a
sequel series or film which might see
buzz lightyear in his gang doing more
proper planet hopping in a campaign
against the villain of course it also
could just be a fun tease that never
comes to anything only time will tell
sitting in the theater it's easy to
assume that the zerg scene is the last
bit of proper content in the movie but
that's not quite true
if you continue to watch through all the
company logos you'll eventually be
rewarded with one last easter egg
derek the star command robot working
with izzy moe and darby early in the
film is shown still working on a route
for the team to take the bot finally
figures it all out only to turn around
and see that the whole team is gone
there are a lot of themes at play in
lightyear the value of diverse
experience the importance of accepting
differences and the problems inherent to
obsessive behavior are some of the most
obvious ones there are also some less
explored themes like zerg's resistance
to different ways of thinking when buzz
starts to disagree with his plan to turn
back the clock zerg angrily complains
that his younger counterpart has so many
new ideas for him there's clearly only
one way to do things the right way and
yet that way would bring immense pain
and suffering if taken to completion
light year isn't just about how we can't
change the past it's about how we can't
stop change buzz finds it bizarre that
100 years after his own original era
sandwiches have meat on the outside and
bread on the inside i am so sorry to
hear that
it's a silly example but it drives him
the point that the world will change
whether you like it or not you can sit
around complaining about how things were
better in the old days or you can accept
the way things are now still light year
shows that in every era there are
constants love family and community
embracing those and not worrying about
the details is the way to find real
happiness if you instead spend all your
energy being angry about the way the
world is changing you might catch
yourself turning into a zerg check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about lightyear
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one